Anette true story
very people knew this ever happened and
[Music]
I'm sitting up my monitor one day and he
says do you know no standing behind so
we talked about putting pork sisig get
out of here and working itself playing
just know Gordon Parks is standing right
behind he's one of my heroes so I turn
around and he says don't get up don't
get up he walks to me
he puts my hand on my his hand on my
shoulder and he says I never stop just
looked at him and walked away I was like
you know given signs from the universe
you know and he was one of the things
that propelled me into continuing
because whenever you get depressed or
something you want to stop and you don't
stop because of those people came along
and said don't you ever think of
stopping cuz I'm not gonna lie to you
there are times I wanted to give up
because it's like hard but then you
think of the people who loved you enough
to encourage you you don't stop and it's
also your family's legacy
could you justify stomping a hill yeah
is it unfair yes if you don't fit no
certain boxes is that prejudice yes are
there people who don't like it because
of the color your skin yes people don't
like it because she was smart isn't him
yes so I mean if the boogeyman is good
his foot on your neck you have one of
two choices he's 10 times bigger than
you see if I say he's 10 times bigger
than me
he's 15 foot oh and my neck is cracking
I'm ice well surrender and go that's one
choice or if his what is near your mouth
you can bite his tongue
I choose toe biting
because you know what the book has totus
it really does look little media chuggy
has meditation helped you notice
gratitude because I think some people
see signs that do tell them to keep
going and and it sounds like you've
you've taken certain things and really
taken that to heart and know that this
wasn't just a coincidence or this this
was I I was meant to hear this I was
meant to have this hand on my shoulder I
was meant to have someone take away in
my journal and what seems like a bad
thing and then she reads it it's
personal but then something great comes
of it
meditation saved my life I was taught
meditation seeing some little meditation
TM that good friend of mine I was in a
Broadway play and doing very well but I
gotten into drugs because there are
times in which the struggle is so
difficult um I was working and
challenges and I just overlong and it
ended up at a point where in a Broadway
play and I'd be late to work I they told
me don't be late anymore and I came lit
again and they said you're not
substitute but your understudy is going
in and I got pissed off and and my
friend who saw this um said bill you're
sinking fast man you have to do
something but I said like what he says I
made like the drugs and alcohol but try
meditation and say
people what they they like here so I got
worse and then she said try it okay I
mean I'll try I here so I tried it a
couple of times it was interesting about
still taking drugs and alcohol and then
after on Oman she said I'll tell you
what I'll make a deal she said if you
meditate for six weeks without taking
any drugs or alcohol of any kind and if
you still want drugs and alcohol after
six weeks
I'll buy you a amounts of anything you
want I'm thinking oh boy
an ounce of anything I want
are you kidding me I'll take this debt
which I just know it's gonna work
it wasn't gonna work first two weeks I
felt something it was like I don't know
when we're easy let's dress second and
third week more focus
fourth and fifth week the piece that I
was getting out of the drugs and alcohol
I was getting to meditation and more I
was getting a deeper sense of something
I can't even explain I haven't touched
drugs or alcohol since that day and that
was in 1974 became a TM teacher it's
changed my life too I can't even tell
you it's it's hard to explain you know I
could tell you more stories about what
I've been through but that was God
working again to join me Chancellor
meditation I changed my life to for my
own salvation can they do who asked me
to turn around and miss Walker and dr.
hall it's and and I recognize these
things that he wasn't gonna think I'm
crazy because I say oh god is doing this
oh whoa what should God look like I
don't know I know he's there I trust
because there are things that have
happened that I know I'll give you
another example it's in my book